thinking of leasing a car well the first
thing to know is that car leases are
unlike any other kind of rental
agreement since new cars lose value so
fast dealerships will want you to pay up
to 40 or 50% of the car's total value
just to have it for the first 3 years
and that money is considered a loan so
you'll pay interest on it just like any
other car loan there are a lot of
restrictions as well most lease
agreements have mileage limits usually
between 12 to 15,000 per year you also
have to return the car exactly as you
received it so no upgrades or
modifications and forget about changing
your mind lease Agreements are
notoriously hard to get out of often
requiring you to pay off the entire
remaining balance all at once so if you
have a car in working order take good
care of it and drive it for as long as
you can and if you're in the market for
a vehicle saving up and buying it
outright or even with a car loan usually
makes more financial sense than leasing
thinking of leasing a car well